one of the all-time best at the position
in terms of playing it at a high level
and being a two-way threat and we're
seeing this guy play as well as possible
talk about Lamar Jackson so we needed to
get with the latest the latest
performance of Lamar's in the book said
to get this man's two cents on the
subject he's Michael Vick how are you
Michael I'm doing great rich how about
yourself I'm great Mike I give you the
floor on the latest well Lamar what do
you think of when you see him play oh
man I just see excitement I see a guy
who was dynamic and is alright plays the
position from a cerebral standpoint and
then when the defense breaks down he
makes him pay and a guy who was playing
in the offense that's built around him
and and you know allow him the
opportunity to be great you know at such
a young age and it's only gonna give him
confidence moving forward this team is
gonna be good for a long time and as
long as they keep this coaching staff
together this team compete for a Super
Bowl four years on it so let's see I
just want ever asked you this when when
you were starting out did you hear
people say that you shouldn't be a
quarterback you should be playing other
physicians did you hear that too you
know ironically rich no one ever told me
that my high school coach made it clear
to the staff at Virginia Tech that I was
to play quarterback and I think people
see my my abilities
and what I could do my arm was strong
and you know I could push the ball down
the field even when I was young so I
never had to deal with you know the
scrutiny of not being able to be a
quarterback when I was young having a
play out of my position and you know I
don't necessarily think or know if that
was the case for Lamar I know you know
some people may have uttered that but I
never thought that NFL scouts would tend
to believe that this guy should be a
receiver or running back I just don't
know if that's true based on what he put
on tape in college well I I know for a
fact Michael that
some evaluators that were knocking on
the door of the national scouts who
handle the combine to say we should
maybe see if he'll do wide receiver
drills I don't know if he was ever asked
to do that but they were and and rich
this is this is my thing rich if you are
a scout if you are a player personnel
and you cut on the film and watch lamar
jackson and college run embody Petrino's
offense how could you
they even fix your mouth to think that
he should be a a receiver you know like
even if he was to fall in the fourth or
fifth round race somebody gets lucky you
know so it's not it's not a it's not a
reason to believe or think that you know
this guy could could not play the
quarterback position if you watch the
taping he watches thoroughly you know
and that's why I find it hard to believe
what I could see why people can you know
look at him to say okay he can be a
receiver you can place him outside
because he had to speed but man if I was
a general manager you know if it was the
first round of Phil's the sixth round I
want Lamar Jackson yeah and I just
remember that draft night to where the
Saints traded up into the first round
and we thought sitting on the draft said
okay it looks like Sean Payton is
looking over the steering wheel and
wants to get his guy once Drew Brees is
gone instead they they traded over to
haven't poor to pass rusher and we were
all sitting there that draft night until
Ozzie Newsome decided to trade into the
the first round for the for the last
picking and snagged him and I'm
wondering if all that all that does feed
into his fire that leads to a guy what
he's doing oh yeah no doubt and I made
the key person a couple weeks ago on
understeery III feel like you know when
I think about Lamar Jackson his
motivation was to come from of course he
loves football because he wants to be
great but at the end of the day that guy
had to sit in a million and fun his mom
in front of his family and and be the
last guy taken in the first round and if
that doesn't kill you fire what does
and you think Aaron Rodgers was one of
the guys who it was passed up you know
as the draft went on and it filled this
fire for a long time and so he finally
won the Super Bowl and you see it in
this play so that's what you're gonna
get from Lamar before but you won't get
a guy that's motivated hungry determined
and wasn't do whatever it takes the wood
has chain to win each and every Sunday
Monday or Thursday mike vick here on the
Rich Eisen show you can follow him on
twitter and instagram at mike vick take
me inside your conversations with lamar
what have you talked with him about over
the years oh man rich when your mom was
in college I I remember our
conversations but I don't really
recommend what was saying I always
remember just trying to help that way he
got silly enough sell this play his game
and if he played his game that the game
would be fairly easy for most
importantly learn the playbook met your
natural abilities show and that's all I
can remember telling them just play your
game and be yourself and you know you
learn the office first and you know I
Lamar was one thing I can't read about
Lamar is that one of Lee's to talk he
says listen
he wouldn't say too much he's just
soaked in every word this one he was you
know sophomore junior year annoys me and
I talking to one of his coaches last
night same server who was his
quarterback coach maybe so told me like
the Mazda guru he he has a photographic
memory he studies his first one in last
one out all the good qualities of a
quarterback and those are the things
that I totally needed to be and he's
doing it and so when you see his game
would you say okay I'll admit that
that's better than what I was able to do
yeah I think our game is similar based
on what it looks like when a play
breakdown lahmacun he can get freaky
outside the pocket and he can make make
the defense pay if they get out of
position that's the similarity
but I think what makes them better is
that the office that he plays in is
suited for you know his skill set and
for what he can bring to the table and
how he can take advantage of the defense
manipulator and when it's built around
you that way
you know sky's the limit because you
have so many options and things that you
can do to compliment you know what the
deepen what the offense is trying to do
and take advantage of what the defense
is doing to try to stop you in the gate
what you're doing and it's just it's
amazing package that they have in this
downhill is heavy wine game shame the
play action getting spread you out so I
just say the system is better than any
system I probably ever played in to take
advantage of what I did I played it some
good systems for his life are suited for
his game they took advantage of the age
well the question isn't I don't mean
this to maybe carp on Dan Reeves who was
your coach but he was old school because
I guess again I would love to compare
that to cuz John Harbaugh is a guy who
has totally reconfigured what they were
doing with Flacco and Reeves was your
God did he do that for you too yeah yeah
dan dan allowed me to you know do the
things that I like to do and it was in
my second year you know quarterback
draws quarterback sweeps quarterback
counters took advantage of my running
ability and mixed it with the passing
game and they need a complete
quarterback he he put me in a position
to succeed he didn't put me in the
position is where I was gonna be a
harm's way and the things that I could
do with my legs he brought it out and he
brought it out naturally and it was
unfortunate out I only had Dan for 2002
and 2003 and then he was gone but I
really liked the progression of who's
naked within our offense and he was he
was dedicated to change it and build an
office around me so in my second year
when I was you know at my best
when I was young and fresh he was doing
the right things to keep me on track and
help us win football games so a lot of
credit to Dan Mike Vick Michael Vick
here on the Rich Eisen show are you Mike
or Michael what are you going by us now
these days Mike Michael don't matter if
you say the bank and you and my presence
and I'm gonna turn around and look okay
very good let's just speak with Michael
for right now you got it Michael Vick
here on the Rich Eisen show I want to
play for you Mark Ingram after last
night's game okay Michael this is what
Ingram because I know I think you might
have been traveling back to the Midwest
this was this is what Ingram had to say
again when he was brought up talking
when asked if if Lamar was the MVP this
is what he had to say
come see me
LJ MVP if you got a problem
come see me just run that back from last
week solemn oh say man people been
trying me but they can't validate their
opinions so LJ for every P what does
that tell you about the way he's won
over the locker room Michael man you
know what ironically I'm here looking at
the screen in the airport and and mocked
them on the screen looking like he's
reiterating what he said last night
that's it it's a lot man when you talk
to some of the guys and the people
within the organization he gained he's
gained their trust
you know he's gained the trust of the
locker room the Claire's around them the
coaches and it looks like they're having
fun and it's easy to have fun with you
winning you're always gonna be tested
when you lose them but you got to enjoy
the ride you got to enjoy what comes
along we're playing in the National
Football League it's a lot of heartbreak
you know it's a lot of hurt and when a
good is good you got to enjoy it and I
think Lamar brings a great deal of
character charisma to the table and it
shows within everybody on that locker
woman here everybody in the locker
moment everyone on the sideline you know
whether it's going good or bad so
crystal ball it for me Michael how does
this season wind up for Lamar personally
and team-wise what do you think
personally I think it'd be contains at
this pace you know here rush for well
over a thousand yards it will grow over
3,000 that's amazing season within
itself he'll make the Pro Bowl and he'll
be playing in the playoffs most
importantly and have an opportunity to
compete for the Super Bowl and there's
nothing better than that there's no
greater accomplishment than that and
ultimately I think you know I'll say
this could be the MVP of the seat of
this 2019 season and it'll be great for
him I'm pretty sure
that's not something he's session
insight I would think that the Super
Bowl is more important but the sky's the
limit for this guy and if this team
makes it to the Super Bowl and they
overcome all odds then you know good
luck you know for anything that has to
compete with them in NFC yeah I just did
the quick math he needs 263 yards to
break your single-season record for most
rushing yards by a quarterback do you
think he gets that I mean watching them
against the Rams last night the way he
gets on the air with and the way they
run the football downhill and then at
things that they hit you play either
scary
the offenses you know predicated to
putting pressure on a deep Lincoln
non-stop whether whether in the run game
with a pass game and it's evident I've
seen the last night person I hate to
break it to you my math skills are
terrible it's a hundred and sixty-three
yards actually is what he needs he sure
is and then last one for you do you
which team that's out there it could be
the team that's coming in this house his
house this weekend in the Niners which
team or the team that he did carve up
and and and then he's got to maybe beat
a second time in the Patriots which team
is best equipped to knock him out if he
sees him in January I would always say
no England Patriots because of what they
do I think there'll be the toughest
challenge a defense ranked number one
right now hose a lot of merit and when
you look at the San Francisco 49ers and
what I've seen them do the other night
versus the Green Bay Packers was a
stunning performance and I didn't know
they was that stout up front they had
good corners and killed linebackers and
you know what they're doing offense but
how Shanahan speaks for itself
it's the same thing you know that the
child was able to produce in Atlanta and
made my wine look you know like a MVP
caliber you know quarterback and that's
what he was
he's doing the same thing with Jimmy G
so I think that 49ers got a chance I
think the Patriots got a chance but it's
all gonna be predicated on what their
scheme is equipped to do and how they
plan to stop Lamar no one has been able
to do it as of yet and I'm waiting to
see somebody you know put the puzzle
together Michael became Michael thanks
to the time travel safe we'll chat down
the line okay we're always thank you
that's Michael Vick at Mike Vick on both
Twitter and Instagram
Fox Sports FS one analyst right here on
the Rich Eisen show for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app